economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida empezamos donald trump
perdió el apoyo de gran parte del sector
empresarial daniela porque tal buenas
noches mire el asalto el capitolio de la
semana pasada le pasó factura no sólo a
donald trump el presidente sino a donald
trump el empresario ya no son sólo casi
todas las redes sociales y el torneo de
2022 de la pgjej que ya no se llevará a
cabo en el club de golf del presidente
también varios bancos y grandes
multinacionales han anunciado que no
quieren hacer más negocios con él
escuchemos
state
el presidente de eeuu dirigió una turba
contra el capitolio mientras realizaba
un recuento de votos legal y
constitucional del colegio electoral a
la luz de este acto criminal la ciudad
de nueva york ha determinado que está en
nuestro poder rescindir todos los
contratos de la organización trump así
que ya no haremos ningún negocio so we
go now wonder aunque el ibex no es caro
y por mencionar solamente algunas de las
que decidieron distanciarse de la marca
trompa y también del partido republicano
por ejemplo el deutsche bank que es el
banco que más utiliza haití en ti
mastercard american expres la cadena de
hoteles marriott entre muchas otras
consecuencia de los actos daniel el
presidente de venezuela rindió cuentas
económicas
nicolás maduro entregó un reporte lleno
de cifras con corte a 2019 y de antemano
culpó de la mala situación que el país
está atravesando a que recibe menos
ingresos petroleros
pobreza general un 17% y la pobreza
extrema en un 4% si de necesidades de
vivienda salud educación etcétera se
tratan estas cifras contrastan con
varias ong
por ejemplo la encuesta nacional de
condiciones de vida que realizan en
conjunto las universidades más
importantes del país dice que la pobreza
está en el 96 por ciento y que la
pobreza extrema está en el 79,3 por
ciento y otro que ya está ya de las
consecuencias es irlanda del norte luego
del brics y si ya está comenzando a ver
sus estanterías vacías apenas dos
semanas después del break sheet debido a
que hay nuevos y más exigentes controles
de aduana los supermercados tienen un
periodo de gracia de tres meses para
adaptarse a las nuevas condiciones sin
embargo los jefes de las principales
minoristas del reino unido- advirtieron
en una carta al gobierno que la
situación puede empeorar y esta fue la
respuesta que recibieron
en este momento las mercancías fluyen de
manera efectiva y en volúmenes normales
entre gran bretaña e irlanda del norte
hasta ahora no se ha devuelto ningún
camión sí por supuesto que están
saliendo a la luz algunos problemas y lo
que puedo confirmar es que si hay
problemas que creamos que son
desproporcionados
entonces no dudaremos en invocar el
artículo 16 y este artículo 16 lo que
permite es adoptar medidas de
salvaguardia si la situación se sale de
control
daniela y el banco central europeo- su
suma a las preocupaciones sobre las
script humanidad si raúl a efe el
organismo christine lagarde volvió a
urgir porque las autoridades económicas
emitan una regulación global por lo
riesgoso que resulta invertir en estos
activos además insistió en que se ha
utilizado para lavar dinero
el bitcoin raúl que es el más utilizado
ha elevado por 10 su valor en menos de
un año pero sigue siendo anónimo y no
tiene respaldo de las autoridades por
ejemplo un usuario que olvide su clave
pierde su dinero y no tiene a quien
reclamarle pero sin duda el mundo está
girando hacia estas monedas virtuales
que generan mucho interés el mismo banco
central dijo haber recibido un récord de
más de 8000 comentarios sobre el euro
digital aunque es un proyecto que por
ahora no tiene en mente nuestra teoría
esa clave danielle indicadores
wallstreet del cerro en terreno mixto
aunque sin grandes variaciones con los
ojos puestos por supuesto en el proceso
de impeachment el contra donald trump en
europa la mayoría de las plazas
bursátiles tuvo pequeñas ganancias con
excepción de londres y en américa latina
hubo resultados dispares con una caída
significativa en la bolsa de sao paulo
cifra el día los 17 mil 900 millones de
dólares que ofreció el grupo canadiense
cuchetas por carrefour el primer
empleador privado de francia el acuerdo
está en fase preliminar y ya el gobierno
francés dijo no no me gusta este acuerdo
así es y de esta manera entonces
llegamos al final de la economía aquí en
francés de cuatro años muchísimas
gracias como siempre buena noche y usted
también buena noche continúe con
nosotros
i
[Música]